so clapping has been banned at Britain's
University of Manchester Student Union
clapping because it triggers anxiety and
discourages people from attending events
and it will be replaced with a silent
version of jazz hands which is said to
encourage an environment of respect
meanwhile totally different story a
Massachusetts professor says that the
label veteran should be expanded to
include peace activists I say the label
professor should be expanded to include
Messi drew lers the one thing these
things have in common besides lunacy is
that they both broken out of the asylum
gates of the local university the seed
pods from that garden of stupid are now
blooming in the real world why is that
because no one wants to say man that's
really dumb we're all bullied - silence
now by the tyranny of grievance nobody
wants to share the risk in calling out
absurdity because that makes you a big
meanie example you're on a subway and a
maniac gets on board he's a babbling
idiot
so everyone what do they do they look
down at their phones why because no one
wants to assume a piece of the risk so
they hide from the maniac then you
realize the maniac is Bill DeBlasio
again he's screaming in an ADIZ your
head aches he won't shut up so now the
joke's on you
you should have complained the moment de
Blasio got on you should have said shut
up and get out of here you're too loud
and stupid for mass transit ideological
excess spreads when everyone looks the
other way whether it's on campus in
Congress and media but maybe for once
it's time let's share the risk it might
be the only defense we have left so
Jesse they also said that clapping makes
people with autism nervous and I think
that was a strategy to use a real issue
to camouflage a silly idea because if
clapping makes autistic or any anxious
people nervous it would be harmful to
keep them from becoming accustomed to it
like what if they want to go to a soccer
game or what if they want to go to a
rock concert they can't because they
wouldn't be used to clapping this is
absurd are you sure this isn't an onion
article you know what did you
double-check we're getting smoked here I
better check with the producer we'll
check
clapping isn't really for the people
that are clapping it's for the person
that's
forming for instance myself like what I
need the clapping to know if my jokes
are landing yes to know if I have the
audience on my side or not I need that
affirmation they're missing that point
also so about Jessie the British the
British are also overlooking something
else home team advantage when you have a
really loud crowd that forces the
opposing team into taking time outs and
they miss communicate and they're also
missing that also so your point about
autism this discriminates against blind
people
why me people can't see jazz hands okay
very discriminatory and getting to the
auditory situation there were some loud
noises around World War two when the
Germans were dropping really loud bombs
yeah on the British and I think the
British generation I think they survived
that the anxiety there that's real
anxiety and they made it out okay yeah
one what do you make of the idea of
peace activists being called veterans I
think that's a great idea because I
think diplomats is really talking about
I mean you saw a peace activist like
some kid marching protesting treat
they're not do it they're talking about
people who have been diplomats
negotiators people who've made an effort
even people gone overseas like with the
Peace Corps the Mormons who said it's
not over that's not a military veteran
no I didn't say you said military but
they didn't say military veterans these
are people who have given up themselves
so I'm a TV veteran wait a minute I'm a
TV veteran themselves I mean when you
think about it they gave it themselves
they did a job they got paid for it when
you put your life on the line you carry
a weapon that's a veteran well our
soldiers get paid for it yeah they get
paid for it but you know what the risk
if you do the old classic risk reward it
wasn't a good idea to be in this line of
work
chances are someone's out there looking
like it's a great risk to go and put
yourself on the line in the piece
growing but one when you put a bullet in
bin Laden's head you're a peace activist
because now bin Laden can't make war
veteran yes you know Dana I I do feel
that the big problem these days is that
nobody wants to share the risk when
there's a when like when there's a
really dumb idea there's a minority of
activists that are so loud that they'll
boycott you they'll come after you
they'll hound you so people just go
that's a good idea nobody wants to share
the risk well as you were saying that it
does all of us for so long when we hear
these fine things like oh that's stupid
yeah and then but you know all of a
sudden now there's an entire generation
of people yeah who think that you know
you can't function
yeah in the real world without all of
this mollycoddling yeah I love that word
it's like British word it's like you
know the speech codes on campus is a
lousy idea but academia they they didn't
want to share the risk they didn't want
people banging on their doors never the
president of the you know that
University in Oklahoma yes who stood up
and he said like we we are not your
babysitters we're not your parents we
are here to challenge your thing and
remember he got all that attention but a
lot of more people should be like that
more people should be willing to take a
risk you know Manchester United by the
way has the loudest soccer fans I don't
know if they're not doing jazz hands you
know what you ever been the Gallaudet
and yes and I tell you what they do lots
of things by the way there are very
aggressive players because they don't
hear the whistles yeah so they keep
fouling but I will say this jazz hands
works yeah what is fro jazz hands
problem